um so we have uh
olia badelka from belarus um
uh strong i am i think 2400 plus
and uh believes she's still a junior
question mark anyway
let's go e5 for once i mainly have been
playing sicilian but
oh okay okay
somebody had to somebody had to
somebody had to okay props
and she is playing for team kramnik and
i desperately need to win
and she she goes ahead and does this
okay
never mind never mind
we'll just play no castling chess i'm
sure yeah she plays for cream team
kramnik who's the proponent of the no
no i'm not gonna repeat moves just once
now i'm gonna punish you
i'm gonna give you a free draw like
who's going to watch that
yeah so now she has to play she has to
play solidly should be four
c5 maybe
i'm just gonna play f6 i guess bishop
please
b6 develop normally not care
too much about the non-castling
non-casting thing maybe i could do
something more violent but
like if i can't castle myself it's uh
it's sort of more more difficult
to um
uh to um
to to to mate quickly um
but i gotta give her props uh
she has the one chance to play against
me
and she goes ahead and bone clouds
so uh
it's both very silly and a little bit
legendary at the same time
i think would be a fair a fair
assessment
h4
maybe i'll just go run the other way
just for fun king d7 and then king c8
i'm just artificially castling queenside
you normally don't do that
i think vlad and vichy are
playing a non no castling
chess match later this year if i'm not
mistaken
i think it's pretty difficult to play
because you gotta
it's a little bit like playing playing
fish random chess 916 that if you just
have a mindset that you try to make it a
normal chess game
as soon as possible uh you're probably
going to lose because you you aren't
flexible
enough to adjust to the new
circumstances because it's
it truthfully told it's very different
from
from normal normal chess especially some
of
some of the positions and um
it's it's very interesting training i
think in general
uh now we'll go e4 next um
and i certainly find it very difficult
to play
to to play fisher not enough to
[Music]
lose as poorly as i did to to wesley
even though he's strong
at the format little tactic here um
but still yeah it's it's hard to play
and non-castling chess i can imagine is
even
it's even tougher go knight e5
ideas of e3 after after c4
uh okay let's go queen c6
try and be solid little trap bishop e5
there was queen b5
rook a1 and rook c rook
oh way too many hours now
way too many hours
um as i said i just drew my first arrow
ever
earlier today so i'm
not used to this
e3 i think
queen queen f3
oh this wasn't so great because she has
the trump in the ending here
okay this i think just loses
okay for keeping it simple
will go and take another pawn
and she's playing fast but i think at
this point to no avail
i have ideas like queen h5 and then f4
winning
the arrows are going astray the arrows
are absolutely
wild at this point i'm not a
good marksman